c'est non non
nous n'avons plus de religion
nous nous les catholiques
c'est vrai si vous demandez un musulman
qu'est ce que vous faites pour le
ramadan il voit bras je vais je n'ai 1
et si vous demandez un catholique qu'est
ce que vous faites pour la pentecôte il
vous répondra c'est ben je vais chez ma
belle-mère
il est grand temps mes frères que vous
vous replonger dans les écritures et sur
vos prie dieu
si vous voulez un jour tâter du ciel et
peloter les anges aujourd'hui catéchisme
prenez un papier un crayon mettez-vous à
genoux sur le gavage bien en titre
je connais bien les grandes fêtes de la
religion catholique premièrement noël
noël célèbre la naissance de jésus
christ fils de dieu venu sur terre pour
effacer les péchés du monde mais il
avait oublié sa gomme
le père de jésus s'appelait monsieur
joseph bien qu'il fût charpentier
monsieur joseph n'avait pas de semences
sa femme madame marie dû faire appel au
docteur saint-esprit qui pratique à
l'opération qui porte son nom
par la suite la mode des mères porteuses
devait tomber en désuétude pendant près
de deux mille ans
de nos jours on fête noël dans le monde
entier dans les pays chauds il arrive
que les gens aillent à la messe de
minuit
deuxièmement l'épiphanie c'est le jour
où les pieds nickelés de dieu melchior
balthazar et j'oublie toujours le
troisième apporte à l'enfant lors la
myrrhe et l'encens la vierge jette la
mire parce qu'elle ne sait pas à quoi ça
sert 3 mercredi des cendres c'est le
premier des 40 jours de pénitence c'est
carrément le carême au cours duquel le
catholique doit moins boire moins fumer
et faire la guerre avec une certaine
modération sauf si c'est l'ennemi qu'a
commencé la veille du mercredi des
cendres c'est le mardi gras les cons se
déguise en imbécile pour passer inaperçu
les rameaux le jour des rameaux jésus
monté comme un pardon
le jour des rameaux jésus monté sur un
âne
jésus monté sur un homme traverse
jérusalem au milieu des croyants en
délire qui l'acclament en ce coin des
rameaux d'oliviers c'est un dimanche en
fin d'après-midi et la foulée tels que
nous retrouvons la foi et notre
correspondant au pc de rosny-sous-bois
vendredi saint c'est le jour de la mort
du christ à 15h le golgotha s'enflamme
de mille couleurs extraordinaires c'est
dieu le père qui fait son intéressant
malheureusement le fils ne peut pas
applaudir
pâques à apax et la grande fête de la
résurrection trois jours après sa mort
jésus soulève la pierre tombale de son
caveau de famille et va prêcher la bonne
parole chez l'apôtre thomas et sa femme
chantal la venteuses du supermoto
l'ascension tout jésus plongé dans une
prière reçoit une poussée de base en eau
qui le renvoie chez son papa c'est le
théorème de l'ascenseur
l'assomption chaque année le 15 août la
vierge marie dont nous avons relevé plus
haut les singularités gynécologique pont
1,9
c'est le pont du 15 août
les protestants qui ne croient pas au
dogme de la vierge ont longtemps marqué
leur hostilité à cette croyance en
allant chez leur belle-mère le jour de
l'assomption 10 enfin la toussaint c'est
leur fête de tous les saints et surtout
de saint fleuriste le lendemain de la
toussaint de novembre jour des trépassés
les catholiques vénère leur belle-mère
en allant chez leur mort
[Musique]
etonnant non